I'm going
good time
I'm the wall
Oh
hey wastelanders welcome back to your
guide for all things wasteland I'm Dave
and I'm here to tell you all about a mod
that's both hilarious and dangerous to
your health the insane hero that is the
modern manza has decided to be a good
idea to make a rocket launcher that
shoots deathclaws so in case the name
didn't give it away this modifiers
deathclaw eggs at anyone whose day you
want to ruin as soon as the reptilian
shell impacts a savage deathclaw spews
forth and will devour any prey that's
within crore distance you can find this
terrifying piece of equipment in a trunk
near the deathblow nest at Linwood's
some of you may recognize this location
from a quest in fallout 4 that involves
you returning an unborn deathclaw to its
parent which makes it feel even stranger
to start firing eggs around the
Commonwealth the weapon maintains the
default skin and customization options
as the bog standard missile launcher
although changing the weapon at your
bench will not actually change how the
thing works so sorry but I'm afraid
there'll be no quad barrel deathclaw
launches I think one is enough for now
it's worth noting that the eggs don't
have any physics so be careful you don't
do my death claw into a life of floating
through space it is quite satisfying to
launch friendly savage death tours into
rey de Kamp's settlements or even
airships and then just sit back and
watch the ensuing chaos play out before
your eyes if the mod create Amanda feels
like making this mod more insane then
I'd love to have the ability to change
what kind of death while spawns as well
as making those customization options I
mentioned earlier actually affects these
ballistic lizard eggs believe it or not
but this weapon isn't law friendly I'm
not sure there's anything in the fallout
storyline that could account for a
missile launch of the launches eggs
instead of explosives but if you want to
mix things up and install something that
isn't a retexture or one of your
bog-standard weapons that don't you x
well then this will provide at least an
hour or two of distraction between quick
saves once you've caused enough chaos
with your death claw friends come back
and let us know what you think of the
mod do you love the silly crazy and
often insane mods or do you keep your
wasteland of pure and only use the most
serious of content we would love to hear
from you to leave your thoughts at the
comment section below or tweet them at
us using the hashtag GS fallout and
until next week when we'll have another
episode and probably a less insane mod
stay safe at their way slander